Oh trigger warning it's Thanksgiving and
you know what that means as you try to
enjoy some downtime with your family
you'll undoubtedly find yourself sitting
across from a social justice warrior at
your Thanksgiving table trying to
force-feed you white guilt after all
it's your ancestors who committed mass
genocide against the Indians I'm sorry
Native Americans I'm sorry indigenous
the ones who do the mouth thing the
plates save and go with Redskins only
one problem what they're trying to feed
you is unadulterated plain roaming
Buffalo feces right supremacist yes
there were some heinous crimes committed
on behalf of the settlers Europeans that
are unforgivable and I've benefited as a
result with white privilege blah blah
blah blah but some of the BS needs to be
called out civilizations clash that's
happened since the beginning of time yes
war sucks but it doesn't give the right
to leftists teachers social justice
warriors to lie about a non-existent
horseback culture peaceful Native
American who was taken out by smallpox
blankets and painted with colors of the
wind
Oh so before you dummies hang that
dreamcatcher from your rear-view mirror
that's another problem we'll talk about
are you planning to fall asleep at the
wheel you're a jackass I don't care if
you do have a dreamcatcher in your car
you fall asleep with a wheel or two tons
of steel glass and gasoline behind you
it's going to be a bad dream no one
wakes up from that refreshed but it's
time to put your surgical masks on like
Japanese do in the face of SARS because
you're about to smell some sacred cows
being burned let's debunk some of the
most common politically correct
Thanksgiving myths myth the Native
Americans were a peaceful culture to
whom the concept of war was foreign fact
many tribes were conquering poles Native
Americans ward with each other since
forever
sometimes it was over hunting or farming
ground sometimes it was revenge but the
truth is the only way settlers were able
to conquer this land was with the
assistance of Native Americans
themselves who wanted to settle the
score with other who they viewed to be
more Polish tribes than themselves
you think Cortez took over stuff with
500 conquistadors no it was the 50,000
plus Native Americans who had it up to
here with being enslaved raped brutally
tortured and forced to carry gold for
the
other native as Dex same thing for the
north a big strategy of the Europeans
wasn't to kill everybody it gives some
tribes some firewater and boom-boom
sticks let them do the dirty work here
have fun some of the Indian sorry
[ __ ] tribes were the most brutal in
existence
some of them practice enslavement rape
cannibalism they would sometimes target
women and children for example the
Comanches would butcher babies and roast
people alive and where do you think we
learned the fine art of scalping Native
Americans were an advanced society truth
not even close
smell that it's your sacred cow and it's
already extra well done don't worry I
scalped her first and made the other
cows watch
unlike ancient Rome Greece China or
really any other advanced empire that
had existed long before we came here
with the Native Americans they didn't
have any kind of advanced plumbing
transportation mathematics or really
anything that's led to you watching this
right now on your iPhone oh you're just
being a snow centric yes that whole
beautiful horseback Indian culture you
read about it's a lie they hadn't even
domesticated horses not only that they
didn't use the wheel no really 1400 AD
no wheel
I said good man why don't you just roll
it you know roll it's ro
I know this one's not a moral argument
the point is when you're that far behind
the clash of civilizations is that much
worse when the wheel using new world
catches up to you miss the settlers
deliberately infected Native Americans
with smallpox blankets to wipe them out
truth only idiots could believe this
think about this for a second you
believe that Europeans waged microbial
biological warfare years before
discovery mass acceptance or even
acknowledgement of advanced germ theory
you can search high and low for
legitimate historical accounts of
smallpox blankets being mass pijama
grams to peaceful Native Americans but
you won't find it however there is some
truth to the myth which brings me to my
next point
myth Europeans deliberately committed
mass genocide wiping out every last
native for sport truth nope this brings
back in our last point it is estimated
that as high as 95 percent of Native
Americans were actually taken out by
diseases why because Europeans brought
with them new diseases to which the
natives weren't immune not only
themselves but with animals with which
the Native Americans had had no contact
with because again they hadn't yet
domesticated horses again not judging
just because of the lack of advancement
as a society no horses are wheels no
wheel sure there were plenty of bloody
horrendous unimaginable conflicts that
did occur and when dealing with a more
barbaric society and new settlers
generally speaking in warfare the guys
with the boom-boom sticks win this is an
exclusive to America and it's not all
uncommon but Europeans weren't hell-bent
on destroying every single last
indigenous person as a matter of fact
they were encouraged to reach out to
them and try and bring them into the
culture and convert them to Christianity
Plus intermarry
was incredibly common how else do you
explain Angelina Jolie Johnny Depp Kid
Cudi and even imaginary Elizabeth Warren
claiming to be 1/16 Cherokee she's quite
pretty father yes she is totally how she
makes me feel woman my will believe it's
my bits too in summation killing is bad
but so is milking misleading and
guilting future generations for crimes
they never committed yes Europeans
conquered the Native Americans
instituted a constitutional republic and
advanced in a mere couple centuries what
Native Americans weren't able to do for
thousands of years beforehand yes it was
violent but once contact has been made
you can't go back if today we never came
here they saw a plane guess what it's
gonna start some so turn off this
smartphone go enjoy some turkey with
your family and be sure to tell your
social justice warrior cousin at the
table to shut his moustache single
origin coffee drinking whole if that
doesn't work just hand him a smallpox
napkin sure many of these depictions are
not historically accurate Lee didn't
have Buffalo Trace or 3-3-7 magnums but
here we are